I'm the boss I know how it should be and
you have to get there
what stops an actor from sharing
themselves and their work
uh Trust
if they don't trust the director if they
don't trust their fellow actors if they
don't feel safe
they will tighten up tense up
so whether I'm on set or in class it's
just building that trust making them
feel that it's a safe space for them to
open up and try things I think that's
the most important thing that I do as a
director as an acting teacher
is creating that space
where everybody can relax
and play and find different things and
try different things
what if they don't trust themselves
can you see that versus they don't trust
others
uh yeah
yeah you can see them editing themselves
you can see them being self-conscious
but I think again that comes back to
creating that that safe space where
you're encouraging them
um not like
picking out
negative things that they're doing but
but coming at it from a more supportive
encouraging positive uh place
and making you know actors are really
sensitive creatures you know so and I
know having come from acting
that one little note can really get in
your head and throw you off you know I
have to always keep myself from giving a
good note too because sometimes that'll
throw them off if you say like oh I love
that moment do that in the next take I
love that moment where you guys said
that thing and you know and then the
next take you can see them in their
heads sort of like oh here comes the
moment that he loved and it will never
be as good you know so I have to that's
the thing I have to constantly keep
myself from doing is like being
supportive and acting like I like what's
going on but not being so specific that
I get in their heads you know
you say let actors play can you tell us
what this means
yeah to try different ways of saying
something to try a improvised line of
dialogue to
maybe take a pause before that moment to
to connect to their scene partner to to
just keep keep exploring it so that I'm
not getting like six takes that are all
in the same sort of place you know
that if it's a
angry line maybe don't say it Angry
maybe you know say laugh
on one take
track keep trying stuff you know so
that's what I mean by play
was being given Freedom important to you
when you were taking classes let's say
in New York City in the beginning do you
remember teachers that you felt maybe
were more controlling versus ones that
really let you do your thing and you
knew that's what worked
yeah I think there's a whole sort of
history of uh coming back to the to the
method uh book that I love so much the
Isaac Butler book but like you know Lee
Strasberg and that of berating people
and I think that's a long history with
acting teachers of that sort of yelling
at people and never acting like anything
is any good
um so I I sort of work against that
um I don't think that creates an
environment where people want to play
and try things if they're constantly
getting berated
um so I think
you know you don't want to just say
everything's great and so you want to
try and
um be constructive with your criticism
but just not in a way that's too
berating or negative
so that brings to the Mind an article I
saw I think Wall Street Journal can a
boss be good if they yell and I'm
wondering if the same is for a director
because I was thinking about it if the
boss is then fair at other times I think
you would almost respect them in some
sense yeah versus a boss that maybe
doesn't yell but then there's like other
stuff that's not I mean that's
interesting could it can a director be
good if they yell
uh sure I mean Lee Strasburg was an
amazing teacher you know even though he
yelled at people
um so I think you can be I think for me
it's getting out of that mindset that a
director is the boss you know it's it's
um I think there's a lot of ego in
directing and teaching and being you
know being in that position
the ego can go wild with that so I think
you have to constantly work against that
and
be a collaborator and I don't want to
direct unless I have to if it's going
off the rails I'll give you a note but
if I can just cast really great actors
and let them do their thing
great
I don't need to micromanage and direct
all the time you know
do you think though we need to know who
to respect you know sometimes you have
to what's the saying you have to meet
people at their own level sometimes to
have them respect you do you do you
think we need to sometimes see that
person take ownership of the ship yeah
but I think that's about I think you see
that in their what they want and how
they communicate and I don't think that
has to be I don't think respect comes
from yelling at somebody or berating
someone I think I think you know you can
be respected and be positive and
supportive and
be collaborative and
um
I think just a lot of times probably
because of that like wanting respect I
think directors tend to direct too much
and it's you know I think it's in in all
aspects of the business you know actors
love to act
and act too much you know so I think
it's
you have to take your ego out of it and
just really focus on the work and the
people that I've worked with that do
that
those are the people that I respect
um
I love when someone says I don't know I
don't know what this moment should be
let's let's figure it out together
I don't think
um I don't disrespect them for that I
think that means that they're still
exploring the moment they're trying to
figure it out with the actors they're
letting something be alive and I respect
that rather than somebody who's gonna
pretend they know the answers all the
time
find the character within them
um
that's a tough one I mean if it's an are
you talking about like in a set or in a
class or because I think that's okay I
mean I guess I'm thinking of maybe
really both anytime they're supposed to
play something and it just it's not
giving it's not coming for you yeah I
mean that's why I would I would never
direct something that I didn't get to
cast because I think casting is
everything and directing so
um I've had the luxury of working with
amazing actors
um so I haven't had that problem on a
set uh in a class it's different because
you're getting you know new people all
the time and people are at different
levels of experience
um
I think there's always a version of the
character that they can find and it's a
version their version of the character
um
so it's not necessarily like
this is the character and you have to
like go to the character and become this
thing it's sort of bringing those two
things together like I want to see your
version of this character
um more than like trying to hit some
note
how do you know when to push an actor
and when to leave an actor alone
um
well if they're not
getting the scene or the or the moment
um in the way that you
see it
then it has to be a communication but I
think
push is a tough word for me just because
I think if you push too hard
you're not going to get what you want
out of that actor so I think it's really
a delicate you know it's just a
conversation about you know I like to
ask questions a lot like what do you
think this moment is what are you what
are you trying to do with this line like
what what's your intention here and
um
because I think sometimes if you
push too much you can push him away
so it's a pulling
sounds like yeah it's more of just a
conversation of just figuring it out
together again rather than it being like
I'm the boss I know how it should be and
you have to get there
rather letting it be a conversation of
like maybe it's that Vision I had but
maybe it's something else you know I
always come back to that I love that
line about you know you write
one movie
you direct another movie and you edit a
third movie you know so it's it it's
always got to be alive
and if you get too controlling and try
to make it something that you wrote six
months ago in the script
it's not going to be alive and it's not
going to be compelling
you said you had side jobs as a waiter
yeah did you work in some hectic
kitchens oh
yeah
yeah talk about uh
yelling and acting teachers yes chefs
can be similar well I mean there's an
element of show yeah you know it's
played up time and it's dinner time and
you've got you know patrons that are
waiting yeah and there's a stress and so
it's similar get out there but you're
right that's a push yeah that and needs
to be obviously but
whereas you're talking about asking
questions and pulling Maybe
yeah just having a dialogue with an
actor and talking about it I mean
hopefully that
can happen in rehearsal and you have
enough time I mean sometimes when it
gets really stressed and you're losing
the light and you got to get the shot
and you know that's that's a different
story but
um but as much as I can keep it alive
and exploring and finding things
um
you know I think that's
the atmosphere you want to create I mean
so many film sets that I've been on it's
just like about like okay did we get it
okay next thing it's like we're not
being creative we're not you know
exploring things we're just like getting
the shot and moving on to the next thing
and it's like the the idea is just to
get the day
um but then what are you making